tout le monde rêve de posséder un sabre
laser on pourrait couper son steak avec
de la lumière mais mes rêves de combat
hippiques ont bien vite été brisées la
première fois que le prof de sciences
m'a présenté un laser au lot c'est juste
de la lumière aux opa met dans les yeux
pas de mouvement pas de lame
surpuissante pas de brad rencher
carbonisés ou lé star wars est vraiment
faire ça malheureusement un laser ne
peut pas devenir une épée à moins que il
y a eu énormément d'innovation dans le
laser découpe laser lecteur de cd fibre
optique chirurgie testons ça pourquoi on
ne peut pas transformer un laser en
lames vont alors déjà un sabre laser ces
composés de quoi dans la poignée du
sabre on trouve une batterie odiah tome
qui alimente deux cristaux kamber ils
vont concentrer l'énergie en un rayon
laser rouge ou bleu vert violet selon la
nature du cristal mais comme tu t'en
doutes pas de dia thiam ou de crise du
kaiser dans notre galaxie
sauf qu'en vrai c'est pas non plus un
délire surréaliste
tu vois ce pointeur laser devine de quoi
il se compose oui oui une batterie et un
cristal pour les pointes de rouge et
s'agit souvent d'un rubis meta vole pas
tu vas pas devenir riche en démontant
des pointeurs laser cd ruby synthétique
la batterie du laser produit un courant
électrique et qui stimulent les atomes
du rugby et quand leurs électrons sont
bien excités ils lâchent la sauce ils
vont émettre des photons des petites
particules de lumière qui vont à leur
tour percutée d'autres atomes et les
stimuler comme les photons sont figés
entre deux miroirs
ils vont faire pleins d'aller retour à
travers le rugby la réaction en chaîne
se produit à chaque collision photons
atom
le peso va être amplifié d'où son nom
light amplification by stimulated
emission of radiation
oui oui c'est la vraie signification du
mot laser j'espère vous avoir appris un
truc là la lumière qui ressort par le
petit trou va être super particulière
puisque déjà le rayon ne se disperse pas
il reste une simple et signe ligne tous
les fautes on vibre de la même façon
comme des petits soldats qui marchent au
pas cadencé
c'est pourquoi le laser peut être aussi
puissant et à une couleur si intense tu
veux changer cette note
pas de problème il suffit de prendre un
autre cristal ou même de remplacer par
un autre gaz mais bon je te vois venir
pointeur laser ça ressemble pas trop à
une arme bah oui et heureusement que
quand tu veux montrer un truc sur ton
diapos tu découpes pas le mur en même
temps quoique fais gaffe si tu te prends
un laser dans les yeux pendant quelques
secondes le rayon reste assez concentré
pour te cramer la rétine un combat jedi
ça pourrait ressembler à des mecs qui
essaye de se [ __ ] un pointeur laser
dans les yeux tout de suite mon style
mais voilà on peut quand même faire des
lasers beaucoup plus puissant dans
l'industrie coupé du métal avec un laser
c'est pas du tout un truc de jedi
c'est même la routine la france est
sacrément balèze dans le domaine
d'ailleurs car près de paris il y à
apollon l'un des lasers les plus
puissants du monde
il peut générer pendant quelques
femtoseconde l'équivalent d'un million
de centrales nucléaires l'étoile noire
n'a qu'à bien se tenir
on se sert d'apollon pour étudier
l'atmosphère terrestre mais ne
pourrait-on pas s'en servir pour la
guerre pendant la guerre froide
on avait lancé un programme appelé star
wars il s'agissait de mes gars lasers
destinés à cramer les satellites et
missiles nucléaires soviétiques avant
qu'il réussisse à atteindre leur cible
une sorte d'ancêtre du blaster quoi sauf
que bah voilà on va pas se mentir il ya
deux trois petits problèmes à régler
avant de pouvoir faire le con avec un
sabre laser déjà à ses rayons lumineux
bega puissant c'est sympa de secondes
mais c'est pas avec deux piles que tu as
les alimenter en fait pour faire fondre
une porte blindée en acier comme quake
jean il faut que le laser maintiennent
une température de moins 1500 degrés
soit une puissance de l'ordre du giga
watts haute tant que produit à réacteurs
à fission nucléaire
et c'est pas très pratique à transporter
bon au pire disons que pour l'instant on
branche le sabre avec un long fil
électrique mais il va quand même rester
un problème comme on l'a dit le faisceau
laser se propage en ligne droite
ça veut dire que tant qu'il rencontre
rien il continue dont ton sabre laser à
une longueur ainsi ni ainsi évident de
l'utiliser dans ta chambre si tu tiens
réellement at-on plafond n'est
d'ailleurs tu t'es jamais demandé où
atterrissent et les tirs de blaster qui
dérivent dans l'espace à la vitesse de
la lumière
c'est quand même vachement dangereux non
ah oui et dernière chose dans sûrement
remarqué au jour avec une lampe poche
que la lumière ça faisait pas
d'ailleurs en vrai tu peux même pas
collisionner la lumière de la terre qui
se croisent
ça fait pas de choc bon alors si on part
sur l'idée de faire un sabre laser
on a une centrale nucléaire sur
roulettes pour te suivre partout lesavre
c'est plutôt un gros pointeur laser et
ça crame tous super surtout que pour te
battre suffirait d'avoir un miroir ça te
rend vers le rayon laser au plein dessus
non on a besoin d'une autre piste à
nouvel espoir
tu l'as compris le truc qui coince et
que la lumière n'est pas une matière on
ne peut pas la toucher enfin pour
l'instant
parce que en 2018 et chercheur du mi6
ont réalisé un vieux rêve de physicien
ils ont réussi à créer des molécules de
lumière tu vois les photons ces
particules fantômes qui composent la
matière pas d'habitude quand deux rayons
lumineux se croisent les photons
n'interagissent pas entre eux ils
s'ignorent royalement bah oui la lumière
ça n'existe pas dans tous les sens eh
ben les chercheurs ont réussi à forcer
les photons à s'associer pour former des
molécules
on peut donc se permettre d'envisager
une sorte de chimie de la lumière et
d'espérer qu'un jour on pourra fabriquer
de la lumière en poudre ou en brique ou
en sabre laser après pour l'instant ça
nécessite une température proche du zéro
absolu et les plus grosses molécules
photonique compte au maximum trois
fautes ont alors qu'il en faudrait des
billions pour un sabre laser
donc on fait quoi moi j'ai pas envie
d'attendre d'être aussi vieux que maître
yoda pour commencer à jouer au jedi
pour les plus pressés il se pourrait
qu'il existe une autre solution
et si depuis le début on était parti
dans la mauvaise direction parce qu'on
s'est dit un sabre laser
ça doit marcher avec un laser mais pas
du tout il existe un état exotiques de
la matière qui pourrait ressembler de
ouf à une arme jedi
tout le monde connaît les trois états
classique de la matière solide liquide
et gazeuse mais il en existe d'autres
tons le plasma dans un atome il ya des
électrons qui orbitent autour d'un noyau
est bien le plasma ici chaud que ces
électrons sortent de leur orbite
ça donne un état énergétique qui peut
couper n'importe quoi la foudre par
exemple est un plasma et devine quoi
piéger un plasma ultra chaud pour
produire de l'énergie
c'est exactement le principe de la
fusion nucléaire
attention on parle pas de fission
nucléaire ça c'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui dans les centrales là on
parle de fusion sans entrer dans les
détails ce serait le graal de la
production énergétique quasiment
et inépuisable c'est la source d'énergie
du soleil on n'arrive pas encore à
récupérer assez d'électricité mais on
étudie dans les réacteurs expérimentaux
les tokamaks ce sorte de deux notes dans
lesquelles le plasma est confiné en
lévitation
ben ouais on est obligé de le maintenir
en suspension parce que tu imagines bien
que sinon il ferait fondre le réacteur
ce secteur vraiment prometteur et
dernièrement en pleine effervescence
d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à demander en
commentaires si vous voulez une vidéo
sur la fusion nucléaire et le fait qu'il
y ait plein de recherche là dessus c'est
très bon signe pour notre rêve de sabre
laser ça voudrait dire que dans quelques
années on ci connaîtra à ces
emplacements pour en faire n'importe
quoi
ouais ok cool mais est ce que le plasma
c'est assez puissant pour découper des
trucs au oui et on ne s'en sert déjà par
exemple on fait des scalpels à plasma
hyper précis pour les chirurgiens coupé
du métal avec tranquille et encore mieux
si deux sabres plasmique se rencontrent
les champs magnétiques qui leur donne
leur forum vont interagir et su
repousser
de quoi avoir un vrai duel et on
pourrait même renvoyer les tirs des
stormtroopers cerise sur le gâteau en
changeant la nature du gaz de départ on
change la couleur de son plasma est là
la morale allures d'un croisement entre
la foudre et le soleil niveau
crépitements et vous
là tu es servi elle aura un style très
kawaï lorraine avec ses petites
étincelles tout ça tout ça quoi
je sais pas toi mais moi je trouve ça
méchamment stylet bon reste quand même
le problème énergétique
mais le truc cool avec le plasma sait
qu'il peut réutiliser une partie de son
énergie pour s'auto entretenir comme un
feu une fois que tu l'as lu mais il
continue à brûler on regarde le soleil
en gros c'est une méga boules de plasma
il est pas près de s'éteindre parce
qu'il lui même sa propre source
d'énergie c'est pas classe non mais
attention je suis l'imaginent allumé un
soleil ça demande une quantité colossale
l'énergie alors démarrer ton savent sa
part est sûrs d'y arriver avec une
batterie de la taille d'un manche qu'on
voit dans les films
là encore les scientifiques ont un
dernier atout dans leur poche et celui
là il semble vraiment tout droit sorti
dans cl ce petit bijou c'est l'anti
matière si si c'est bien réel
chaque particule possède son antimatière
une sorte de jumeaux maléfiques qu'en la
matière rencontre l'antimatière elle se
désintègre mutuellement et leurs masses
est intégralement convertie en énergie
c'est l'équation bien connu
égale mc2 et cette réaction est un
milliard de fois plus puissante qu'une
réaction nucléaire s'est littéralement
la forme de stockage d'énergie la plus
compacte de l'univers s'il a maintenant
tu lâches et un gramme d'antimatière sur
le sol ça produirait l'équivalent d'une
explosion nucléaire donc évident s'il te
plaît en fait une pincée d'antimatière
suffirait à alimenter un sabre laser
pendant plusieurs oem et tu vas me dire
c'est forcément trop beau personne ne
s'est fabriqué dans l'antimatière ça
serait quand même et d'ainsi en fait
depuis 2006 la nasa cherche à contrôler
et l'antimatière et le cern a finalement
réussi à fabriquer un anneau gramme
d'antimatière
mais pour la stocker à l'abri de tout
contact on doit la faire léviter sous
vide dans un champ magnétique
sauf que va il est là le problème ça
coûte 45 mille milliards le gramme
en fait l'antimatière et la substance la
plus chère au monde largement devant
l'or et le diamant
mais bon qu'est ce que des tristes
billets quand on peut posséder un sabre
laser
au final même si on s'est basé sur
beaucoup de suppositions toutes les
technologies tous les savoirs sont déjà
là pour créer un sabre laser
mais alors pourquoi aucun ingénieur
s'est dit je vais en fabriquer un
peut-être parce que c'est pas une très
bonne idée
combattre au sabre laser ça serait hyper
gore imagine t dans son labo tu as
réussi à fabriquer un sabre laser
tu t'approches de ta création tu la
prend en main et fébrilement tu appuies
sur l'interrupteur que tu chrome
instantanément mais qu'est ce que tu as
cru je ne serai pas un petit peu
enflammé pendant que tu te tord de
douleur dans les flammes
tu as une petite pensée pour jean d'arc
[Musique]
et aussi à quel point tu es tu es
stupide qu'est ce que tu fous avec ça
dans les mains bah oui chaque objet
diffuse un peu de sa chaleur par un
rayonnement quand tu fais du feu t'as
pas besoin de toucher les flammes pour
sentir la chaleur et dans le cas de ton
sable ce rayonnement c'est un sacré
paquet duvet alors même à distance
respectable oublie pas tes lunettes et à
crème solaire ici tu veux te tenir à un
mètre c'est chaud va falloir de sacrés
protection est pas du genre de truc que
porte un jedi
à moins que des gants épais un masque de
soudeur
tout s'explique et les autres comment
ils font bah ça ça doit être sûrement
grâce à la force donc prévoit de
t'acheter un beau choc dominical rien en
passant à la pharmacie alors ok faisons
comme si le rayonnement ça n'existait
pas on va dire tu as une combinaison
talent août on sabre tu va vouloir
découper un mec ça devrait bien se
passer normalement vu que ça coûte déjà
du métal va en fait il se pourrait que
ce soit un peu trop chaud ton corps est
composé de beaucoup d'eau et quand on
sabre va rentrer en contact avec way
méga jets de vapeur et quand l'eau passe
à l'état gazeux
son volume est multiplié par mille c'est
à dire qu en découpant ton adversaire
c'est d'énormes quantités de gaz va être
éjecté super vite hors de sa blessure
dans le jargon on appelle ça une
explosion vapeur ça va être un carnage
de sang et de boyaux on sera pas
vraiment dans l' arme de précision du
futur
le pire c'est que en solo reste en
contact avec plus de 15 secondes c'est
suffisant pour vaporiser la moitié de
son corps morale de l'histoire
si un jour quelqu'un te menace avec un
sabre laser prend un verre d'eau et j'ai
plus dessus le mec se fera brûlé par une
explosion de vapeur
tu peux même approché un gros aimant et
bane rediriger le rayon vers lui vous
l'aurez compris fabrique un sabre laser
c'est chaud et comme on l'a vu la
science trouve quand même moyen de
repousser inlassablement les limites bon
avec des conséquences pas toujours
attendus j'espère que scientifiquement
vous avez pu apprendre des trucs
c'était cool de partir d'un exemple
rigolo pour apprendre des choses si ce
genre de format vous plaît s'il vous
plaît abonnez-vous à la chaîne on vient
juste de commencer surveillance trash
merci d'être toujours plus nombreux
merci aux monteurs le sens de nous avoir
aidés sur cette vidéo dit mon
commentaire qu'est ce que vous feriez
avec un sabre laser je suis sûr que vous
aurez pas mal d'imagination on se revoit
la semaine prochaine
allez les avis